Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Vous avez les yeux marrons,
vous voulez un enfant aux yeux verts.
Vous êtes bête.
vous voulez un enfant intelligent.
Ici, c'est possible.
Bienvenue à Gattaca.
Ce film de 1997 rend possible
les modifications des embryons
pour que vous puissiez choisir
précisément l’enfant de vos rêves.
Mais si ce n’est qu’un film,
cet imaginaire est aujourd’hui réalité.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Tout le vivant est constitué de cellules.
Une cellule, c’est un peu
comme une machine
qui fonctionne grâce
à un programme : l’ADN.
En 1953, on découvre
que tout l’ADN du vivant
est composé de quatre lettres :
A, T, C, G.
Que vous regardiez dans votre voisin,
dans votre chien
ou dans le plat que
vous avez mangé ce midi,
vous retrouverez ces lettres.
Elles forment le code génétique
dans lequel il y a des mots, les gènes,
qui disent à quoi on ressemble,
comment on fonctionne.
Moi par exemple, j’ai dans mon ADN
le mot : « œil marron ».
Il est dans les cellules de mon œil,
et dans toutes mes autres cellules aussi :
celle de ma peau, celle de mes poumons,
celle de mes cheveux.
Toutes les cellules de mon organisme
ont exactement le même code.
Alors, pourquoi ne suis-je pas
qu’un énorme œil marron ?
Comment se fait-il qu’il y ait
des cellules différentes
avec une fonction différente ?
En 1961, on comprend pourquoi.
Le code est le même, certes,
mais il n’est pas lu de la même manière.
Le programme choisit
de lire tel ou tel mot,
ce qui, d’une cellule à une autre,
change les instructions.
Mais que se passerait-il si on décidait
de modifier le code initial ?
Le programme fonctionnerait-il toujours ?
C’est ce que l’on va découvrir
dans les années 70,
grâce à l’ADN recombinant.
Cette technologie permet de copier-coller
des gènes d’une cellule à une autre,
d'une espèce à une autre.
C'est le génie génétique.
L’objectif : donner de nouvelles
fonctions aux organismes.
Par exemple, mettre dans une tomate
un gène qui les empêcherait de pourrir.
Voilà un OGM.
Il sera un échec commercial.
Le génie génétique,
ce n’est pas assez efficace.
On ne peut pas en faire
de produits industrialisables.
Mais l’histoire ne s’arrête pas là.
Dans les années 90,
les ingénieurs s’intéressent
de plus en plus à la biologie.
Pour eux, le génie génétique,
ce n'est que du bricolage.
Eux, ils peuvent faire mieux.
En appliquant les principes
de l’ingénierie à la biologie,
ils peuvent créer du vivant
vraiment utile.
Grâce à la biologie de synthèse,
on peut
construire, morceau par morceau,
du vivant qui n’existe pas dans la nature.
L'idée est de faire du vivant
un objet comme les autres.
Construire du vivant serait comme monter
une étagère ou fabriquer une voiture.
Il suffit d'avoir une notice
et des pièces à assembler.
Comme celles-ci.
Les ingénieurs considèrent en effet
que l’ADN est constitué de briques
et qu’en les assemblant, on peut
construire différentes choses.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’on peut construire
en biologie de synthèse ?
Prenons un navet.
Faisons ensemble ce soir, un navet
qui aurait le goût
et la couleur d’un bonbon.
Pour cela, on a besoin
d’un châssis, comme celui-ci.
Un châssis génétique,
c’est une molécule d’ADN simplifiée
de laquelle on a retiré
tous les gènes superflus
pour laisser la place juste
aux briques qui nous intéressent.
À mon navet, je vais ajouter une brique
qui va lui donner une couleur
de bonbon rouge.
Je vais également lui donner
un goût un petit peu acidulé.
Mais je veux que dans mon jardin poussent
des navets d’une autre couleur.
Cette fois, je vais ajouter une brique
qui va lui donner une couleur bleue,
ainsi que le goût qui va avec.
Je vais mettre un régulateur,
pour que poussent alternativement
des navets bleus,
rouges, bleus.
Ce que je viens de faire,
tout le monde peut le faire.
Même vous chez vous, ce soir,
vous pouvez sur Internet
acheter un synthétiseur à ADN,
commander les briques qui vous intéressent
et commencer à construire du vivant.
L’idée de la biologie de synthèse,
c’est que chacun chez soi
peut créer tout ce qu’il veut
à partir du vivant.
Mais qu’est-ce qu’on crée ?
De nouveaux matériaux, par exemple.
À quoi ça pourrait ressembler ?
Je vous invite à fermer les yeux.
Imaginez-vous
installé au fond d’un canapé en cuir,
non pas en peau animale,
mais en fibres de champignons,
contre un coussin en soie tissée
en toile d’araignée
génétiquement modifiée.
Imaginez-vous là, en train
de déguster un plateau de sushis
au riz enrichi en vitamines
et aux poissons nés de cellules
artificielles en laboratoire.
Tout ça existe réellement.
Et si
on peut créer tout ça,
alors on peut tout faire,
jusqu’à modifier du vivant humain.
Bienvenue à Gattaca,
ce n’était pas en 97, c’était hier.
En 2018, un scientifique a modifié
le génome d’embryons humains
pour les rendre résistants
au VIH et il a réussi.
Le vivant sur mesure,
c’est maintenant que ça se passe.
De plus en plus d’entreprises
de biologie de synthèse émergent.
Leur objectif : faire du vivant un produit
industrialisable.
Mais si on fait du vivant
un produit de consommation,
il va nécessairement entrer
dans une logique de marché.
Ce vivant créé va être breveté, privatisé
et même les objets de la recherche
pourraient être réexploités.
Actuellement, des utérus artificiels
en développement pourraient
devenir des produits de consommation.
Les femmes pourraient faire appel à
des entreprises qui loueraient des utérus
pour externaliser leur grossesse.
Il y aurait de la pub :
« N’attendez plus neuf mois
grâce à nos super nutriments. »
« Pour deux utérus loués, une petite
modification génétique offerte. »
Alors,
soyons clairs, je ne suis pas là
pour promouvoir ça.
Je ne suis pas moraliste
et je ne suis même pas biologiste.
Mais quand j’étais au lycée,
je me passionnais un peu pour la biologie
et je me disais que ce serait super
si on pouvait hybrider les espèces,
faire un mélange entre renard
et lapin, singe et humain.
J’en parlais à mon prof de SVT,
mais j’ai vite compris que
la biologie, ce n’était pas ça.
Un peu déçue,
je suis donc devenue philosophe.
Ou en tout cas, je suis allée faire
des études de philosophie.
Et là, je vous vois vous dire :
« C’est quoi le rapport
entre tout ce qu’elle nous raconte
depuis dix minutes et la philo ?»
Mais en philosophie,
tout ça, c’est possible.
Qu’on crée du vivant ou non,
peu importe, l’idée existe.
Et nous philosophes, ce qui nous
intéresse, ce sont les idées.
Alors, je me demande :
« Comment l’idée de la biologie
de synthèse se construit-elle ? »
C’est ça, l’objet de mes recherches,
de la thèse que j’écris.
J'écris l'histoire de cette volonté
de créer du vivant.
La biologie de synthèse est une réalité.
Mais laquelle ?
Et qui l’incarne ?
Pour le moment, ce sont les entreprises.
Certaines cherchent
à ressusciter des mammouths,
d’autres à rendre Mars habitable,
ou encore, à créer une vie 2.0
en changeant les lettres de l’ADN.
Mais,
tout ça, ça se construit sans vous.
Pas à l’échelle d’un mammouth,
mais, déjà vos médicaments,
votre nourriture.
Nous pouvons tous,
pourtant,
participer à la construction
du monde de demain.
Nous pouvons tous faire en sorte de
prendre la direction d’un monde biocentré.
Un monde où
le vivant est préservé,
tout en en faisant un produit économique.
Un monde à la solarpunk.
La biologie de synthèse
peut être la passerelle
vers une alimentation
et un environnement plus sains.
Vers une médecine de plus en plus
personnalisée et efficace.
La biologie de synthèse
peut être la passerelle
vers un monde prospère
mais préservé, que vous imaginez.
Le défi le plus immédiat étant
celui de votre imagination.
Quel monde voulez-vous construire ?
(Applaudissements)